في الباحه الخلفيه لاوكرانيا يتصاعد توتر
قد يهدد جبهتها المشتعله مع روسيا بعدما
حققت تقدما ملحوظا في استعاده اراضيها
بدعم غربي التهديد ياتي بسبب الخلافات بين
المانيا وبولندا بشان تزويد كييف بالاسلحه
حيث تتهم وارسو برلين بالتقاعس في ارسال
الدبابات الى الاوكرانيين حتى وصل الامر
بوارسو الى التهديد بارسال دبابات المانيه
الى جبهات دون موافقه برلين المانيا كانت
اعطت الضوء الاخضر بارسال عدد محدود من
دبابات لوبارد لكن البولنديين يقولون ان
نموذج الاقدم الذي التزموا بارساله سيكون
محدود الاستخدام دون قطع غيار المسؤوليه
الرئيسيه تقع على عاتق المانيا المنتج
الرئيسي لتلك الدبابات
كنا نحط الجانب الالماني منذ فتره طويله
على الانضمام الى التحالف وليس فقط تسليم
الدبابات وقطع الغيار ايضا الخلاف بين
البلدين ليس جديدا اذ تحيي وارسو مطالبها
مرارا بالتعويض عما تكبدته منذ ايام
الاجتياح النازي لاراضيها تعويض تقول انه
يبلغ تريليونا وثلاثه مليارات دولار
المانيا اعتبرت نبره جارتها الحاده ليست
الا مسرحا سياسيا قبل الانتخابات المقبله
وستزول مع نهايه الانتخابات التي تكلف
الحزب الحاكمه قبضته في البلاد